yes with a tiny bit of echo but
hopefully that'll go over uh yeah I can
I can see you from the back which is a
little bizarre but uh it works now
okay
yeah so so our next speaker is uh
Professor Adam Smith from Boston
University Adam we're keeping it
informal so take it away
uh okay
um hi everyone I'm sorry I couldn't be
there in person I'm I much prefer of
course to to be there with you
um uh I'll be talking about memorization
and machine learning and this is Joint
work with my student Gavin brown or soon
to be former he's graduating and heading
off to University of Washington as a
postdoc uh Mark bun uh my colleague here
at bu and our collaborators Vitali
Feldman who know Paul were at Apple
um I don't see the audience very well I
kind of have this weird back of the room
with you as I said so by all means
interrupt with questions ask you know I
I won't know when you're asking a
question unless you speak up so sorry
about that
uh okay so
uh you know machine learning models
contain information about their training
data I'm not telling you anything you
don't know
uh and the question we set out to
understand is sort of like you know just
just how much information about their
training data do they really need and
what exactly do we mean by even
formulating a statement like that
so um I'll talk talk about two papers
one that appeared in stock uh two years
ago now uh where we show that in natural
settings
memorization of nearly entire training
examples is necessary for accurate
learning
even when a lot of the details of these
training examples is Ultimate are
ultimately irrelevant to the task at
hand
and then the other second paper
looks at
um not so much sort of how much
information does the model have to
contain but how large into what what
kinds of intermediate states do we need
when we're training a model
and we give again what I claim are
relatively natural problems where every
one past learning algorithm requires
um very large intermediate memory
because of the need to memorize
individual training examples and again I
will try to explain what I mean by that
when I get there
okay but I'll uh I'll start with this
first thing and I'll talk about it and I
maybe I should start by saying one of
the reasons I chose this topic for this
Workshop is both I find the results
interesting and compelling
um but they are both sort of very
information theoretic in their
uh in their kind of both in the
statements but also in the proofs uh and
so they they kind of highlight the role
that the sort of information theoretic
perspective that this
the it Community brings to these
problems can really be useful
okay so what do I mean you know when we
talk about memorization and machine
learning you know sometimes that's
extremely explicit like so for example
if I have a you know a one nearest
neighbor classifier as pictured on the
on the left here uh then the description
of the classifier pretty much is the
entire data set and so like you're
memorizing because that is what you want
to do uh and there are other models
where it's so like almost as explicit
like for example for support Vector
machines the standard dual form
description of a support Vector machine
basically it consists of the exact
descriptions of several data points in
the space
um but memorization is often also like
an unintended side effect or seems to
show up as an independent side effect of
learning
um so for example you know way back in
the days of gpt2 before we had the
current
um even even before we had the current
very large models that are driving
um
you know these these chatbot AI
interfaces uh there's a paper looking at
how gpt2 when prompted with uh training
prefixes of training text will like spit
out as a suffer you know a suffix which
contains for example exact addresses
from its training
more recently people looked at you know
stable diffusion which is a one of the
you know this is a specific instance of
a stable diffusion model for generating
images
um and what you have on top and on
bottom on the top are generated images
and on the bottom are images from the
training data set
um and they match up as you can see
nearly exactly
uh okay so so these models that we're
training they pick up on all sorts of
like individual features of their
training examples like very specific
stuff
and uh you know one might conjecture
that that's just
um
you know you know a mistake that is
because we're not training the way we
should and and maybe that's true in many
cases
uh but you know there's also this kind
of emerging understanding that you know
overfitting in particular ways is often
beneficial to the learning process uh
that sort of contradicts classical
learning theory uh Circa you know 10 or
30 years ago uh and and so that you know
you can sort of view the work our work
is kind of fitting into that larger
thing
okay so when I say say memorization I
want to be clear that I don't mean just
overfitting or like interpolation
through the data in the case of a
supervised model right so very often
when people do talk about that that's an
important and interesting topic so for
example you know the classical machine
learning theory says you know you
shouldn't overfit you should come up
with these parcelonious models that are
whose description length is far less
than the attribute the data set
or even the label Set uh on the other
hand we know that you know it's often
the case that her current models overfit
like crazy and it works pretty well
um and indeed there was a sort of nice
paper by our colleague you know cataly
Feldman that showed that you know there
were natural problems where memorization
of training labels was really necessary
it wasn't even specific to a particular
architecture or style of learning you
know
form of learning algorithm is just like
fundamental to the problem any algorithm
that's sufficiently accurate
okay so you know that work looked at at
this sort of interpolation where you you
fit the labels of your data in a
supervised problem what we're going to
look at is not not just memorizing
labels but memorizing the actual
features nearly entire descriptions
of
um
the the training examples
okay and and of course to even
um you know maybe like one of the
interesting questions we had to answer
along the way to like writing this paper
is well what exactly should we do we
even mean by this question like what do
we mean by a statement that we memorize
examples when you know you're supposed
to be learning something about the
problem and so somehow you want to tease
those apart
all right but I'll get there uh in a
minute
okay so so here's that kind of I'll give
you like a first pass version of our
result which is not in which is sort of
inaccurate and a pretty fundamental way
uh and then I'll I'll you know repair it
after that okay but let me just first
give you the basic setup
um this is sort of classic supervised
learning setup we've got a data set that
consists of n rows drawn IID from sum
distribution Little P
uh and each row uh consists of D
features so these are Each of which is a
bit so I've got it like a binary Vector
length D for each example and a label
which could be a bit or maybe something
a little more complicated
um and you know it it's not necessary
for the results but it's like helpful to
think of d as even bigger than M so very
high dimension set
all right and then we've got a learning
algorithm that takes these inputs and
processes them and produces a classifier
and then we're going to evaluate the
class you know we want to measure
accuracy in the sort of standard way we
would do in supervised learning where
the
um
we we take a test data set a test record
from the same distribution that the data
came from uh and I've run it through the
classifier and check if the label the
classifier predicts is the same as the
label that we you know that came with
the example
okay so our error is just
misclassification
okay and the question as I said is uh
that I'm interested in is sort of what
you know how much information about X is
sort of has to be like baked into this
model yeah
and roughly speaking what we show is
there are natural tasks I'll try and
convince you what natural means but
roughly like of the flavor that people
really you know solve in machine
learning uh that
uh such that for every learning
algorithm
whose error is like close to Optimal for
the sort of task at hand
uh let's say within some you know 10
prediction or misclassification error
the best the best learning approach
then the mutual information between the
data and the classifier
has to be uh large
okay and and how large well you know the
data here consists of n times D B well n
times D plus one or something
bit so let's just call it n times D and
so we're getting you know at least some
constant fraction of that
in the model
okay
so
uh already this is like I I think a
fairly striking statement
um if you sort of think about it for a
little bit like maybe you're you should
be a little skeptical because
um
you know if if for example if if you
already knew what distribution the data
were coming from
then uh your learn if the learning
algorithm knew the distribution p
then it could just ignore X it could
generate its own it could like sample
its own fresh data on its own right it
wouldn't even have to look at the input
data
um so sort of
as stated this result is is false but
I'll like refine it in a little bit but
to first I want to give you a flavor of
like what kinds of problems this might
make sense
is my this for what kinds of problems
with this phenomenon might occur
okay so let me give you one example so
we've got the setting where data they
come from some kind of clusters
and
um
what I mean by a cluster I'll call it a
hypercube cluster so these are uh within
each clutter cluster the data are drawn
uniformly from sum uh sub cube of the
hydrocube so there's a certain number of
a sparse set of bits that are fixed and
the remaining bits are filled in
uniformly at random
okay and within each cluster there's a
different set of fixed bits
and the label of an example is just the
name of the cluster it came from
okay so this is a you know obviously
like a binary problem it's not exactly
the kind of thing we you know normally
solve but it's sort of like you can sort
of see how it it contains like a a lot
of sort of geometric learning type
um like it's sort of a stylized version
of a lot of kind of nearest neighbor
type clustering uh settings where the
you know the Clusters are the points
within the cluster are closer together
because they share some number of bits
then random points are from different
clusters
um and the uh and uh just to be clear
that the labeling task is given a fresh
point from one of these clusters you
have to figure out which cluster it came
from
okay now just to give some intuition to
what's going on if I've got a cluster
from what if if I'm looking at a cluster
where I got lots of examples in my
training data
then very quickly I'll like be able to
filter out which bits are in for the
with that cluster which bits are fixed
and which ones don't matter
and I can just remember you know a
subset of those fixed bits and that'll
give me like a little fingerprint that I
can use to identify future points
but if I'm only given one or maybe two
examples from a cluster
then I don't really have enough
information to figure out which bits are
fixed and which bits are random
but if I go and throws a bunch of bits
out or sort of project down to some
lower dimensional representation then it
you know provably but at least
intuitively for now
um I I throw out like the good
information along with the bad I'm
throwing out the baby with the bath
water
and so what you know basically in a
nutshell what we argue is in these
settings where you've got these sort of
sparsely represented subpopulations then
you have to remember all sorts of
information about your examples even
though it's like totally irrelevant to
the task at hand in the long run like if
you had more data you would totally just
throw all this stuff out almost
everything
but you don't necessarily have more data
and so you have to keep these things
okay so that's just a flavor of examples
again uh if questions are well and
interruptions are well
I have no idea if anybody's raising that
all right so
um let's sort of here's the first pass
statement I gave you again again this
one as as written is false but let me
now give you a statement that's actually
true
all right so the first thing I told you
is that like in order to prove any
statement like this we somehow need the
learning algorithm not to know the
problem it the exact distribution for
which it needs to solve this this
clustering problem this labeling or
supervised you know prediction problem
okay so what we'll do is we'll assume
there's some meta distribution queue on
problem instances and and a problem
instance is a
uh Distribution on labeled examples
and so so that's the thing that it's
like a population a big population and
this Q is like a distribution over those
distributions
so the algorithm is allowed to know the
kind of meta distribution but not the
specific instance it has to solve
because we want to force the algorithm
to actually look at its state
all right and so now there's a natural
task and this task queue depends on the
dimension and also on the sample size
such that for every algorithm
um that achieves error close to the
optimal
error for this meta task queue
then the mutual information between
um
the model and the data even conditioned
even to an observer that knows the task
at hand that actually understands the
population from which the data were
sampled
has to be very large
okay so again P Little P is a problem
instance it's a distribution unlabeled
examples big p is a random variable
which takes values in these problem
instances and it's chosen from this meta
distribution
and here the optimal error uh here this
is sort of the optimal error we get for
the
um the optimal the error of the optimal
learning algorithm the sort of Bayes
optimal strategy if you know q but but
not the specific population you're doing
okay so this is actually a theorem you
can you know pick on
actually a true state
okay I guess the only part that's not
theoremi about this is like whether or
not this counts it's a natural task you
know obviously that's a subjective
assessment
all right so
um
so the point is that that by
conditioning
the problem description
we're basically saying like the model
has to be storing stuff
that is not actually relevant to the
prediction problem at hand
like if it had more data it could
eventually not have this problem
but because it's dealing with a finite
amount of data
it may have to you know store extra
information or in these problems it has
to store extra information if it wants
to sort of do as well as it could for
the amount of data it has
which is normally what we're offering
you know what we're trying to do
all right
um okay so this is a the first you know
first true version of the theory the
result we can actually refine it a
little bit and and say even more about
like what exactly we're trying to store
what exactly is being stored
okay and so specifically
um
what we actually show is that like for
these problems for every data set
there's a subset of the rows that are
kind of special examples so these are
what we call Singleton so these are
examples that are somehow uh loan
representatives of their little
subpopulation
um
and and the and there are two properties
that this set has so first of all uh the
set is typically big so it's generally a
constant fraction of the data set
overall
and secondly for every learning
algorithm that is sufficiently accurate
the information about
this subset
is
um at least is basically the the number
of bits
of in those examples
uh up to some small correction factor
that depends on how how accurate you are
so what this is saying is that you know
for these problems the the mem the
learner's store is an essentially
complete description of like this large
subset of examples
okay at least in the Shannon information
sense
um now uh
one of the thing the things like there
are a number of interesting points to
make about this result I think uh one of
them is that we don't know how to make
it necessarily algorithmic in all cases
so this is an information theoretic
statement that doesn't mean that there's
an efficient extraction algorithm at
least we don't know how to show there is
one
um although as I'll talk about in a few
minutes
uh
we have some experiments suggesting that
that actually typical at least for the
learning algorithms that we use on a
day-to-day basis these there really is
an efficient extractor and it's not that
hard to build
um
yeah so so this is the main result
questions
I'll keep going
um okay so you know there's there's
obviously other other related work uh
the the most Salient is this work of
Feldman that sort of shows that labels
have to be memorized there's this really
nice line of work on Learners that leak
little information about their inputs uh
which is sort of related to
differentially private learning
um and and and in particular there's
this kind of work on Lower bounds for
pack-based learning by Olivia and
that came out around the same time about
a year earlier
um and there's a way to reinterpret what
they do in the setting we consider
uh you know or not for the problem well
yes for not exactly for the problems we
can say whatever
um and there they get a lower bound of
something like n log D it's maybe n log
logd and log D it's not entirely clear
um what the best thing you can get with
their argument but it's not better than
n log d uh you know versus you know
Theta n times D which is sort of the
kind of thing we're getting
um there's another equally interesting
line
representation complexity where people
look at like well how big a model do you
need just to represent a an accurate
answer for the problem at hand
Okay so
um
so this is actually you know what these
Works actually do is they lower bound
the mutual information between an
accurate model
and the popular the problem you're
trying to solve
as opposed to the mutual information
between the model and the data
um but also like in our settings
um
like P is small
so it's like and it's little o of n
times D it's like N squared of D or
something like that
um so so you know these are the so the
issue is not that there it does not
exist in our setting there exists a
small model to explain
the a small predictor
uh that would do very well in fact there
exists a predictor of sizes about n
Times log D for these problems
um because you just need to kind of
remember a few fixed positions to nail
down a cluster
uh so so it's not that the model has to
be big to solve the problem it just has
to be big to to solve the problem using
a limited amount of data
uh and this is related to some time
space trade-offs for learning I'll get
to that a little later and maybe just
some other stuff that you you know if
you're willing to cast a wider net then
there's lots of other related
interesting topics like information
bottlenecks minimum description link
learning and stuff
but um maybe let let me talk about a
different sort of category of
implications of the you know
relations this work what what this work
tells us which is I got into this
thinking you know I can't I my a lot of
my work is on private data analysis and
sort of that's got what got me thinking
about
then potential necessity of this type of
memorization
um but there's this other interesting
aspect of it which is trying to
understand
why we why we we train such huge models
these days
uh there are lots of explanations but in
the if you look at sort of the theory
literature on this there's a broadly
three categories of explanations that
I've seen although I'd be happy to hear
about others one uh the basic simplest
one is just expressivity you know the
bigger the model the more functions you
represent
it's more or less self-explanatory
um another kind of remarkable feature of
the of neural networks is that as you
expand the number of wires and nodes in
the network it often kind of flattens
out the optimization landscape in a way
that allows you to use very simple
optimization algorithms like you know
SGD or and it's it's variance you know
momentum and stuff like that
um and so like often increasing the
model makes optimization easier which is
kind of counterintuitive but but cool
and then another related thing is that
once you're using these very simple
models like SGD very simple optimization
algorithms like SGD they give you some
kind of implicit regularization that
means that the model generalizes well
even though it's got this huge
description
uh
um but I'd like to stress that that our
results you know point at a a very
different an alternative very different
explanation that's complementary to the
others
which is that large models store
information allow us to store
information about our training examples
whose usefulness just isn't yet
understood
because we don't have enough data
for example in as in our work where
there are sort of small population small
sub populations
but also I think this isn't reflected in
our work but I think it's a reasonable
theory is that a lot of the kind of
reason for the the hugeness of modern
models comes from the fact that we want
to adapt the same model to many
different tasks that we haven't yet
encountered
and so we sort of store all this
information about our training data the
model ends up being like a relatively
efficient only slightly compressed
representation of the entire data set
because that allows us to go back and
change our minds later about what
exactly we wanted to do
all right I've got a few minutes left
um I'm happy to take questions or not
have any questions
but Adam why don't you finish and then
we'll have questions yeah sure sure yeah
I just like the format doesn't allow me
to see you
sorry okay so
um let's see I'm a little short on time
we we implemented this uh for some
simple models simple you know simple
distributions to see what happens I I
guess I'll just flash like this one
picture here which is like you know if
you look over here
um this is we're training some you know
multi-layer
just two layer neural network on on the
problem that's basically the one that
comes up in our theorems
and what you get is this sort of really
interesting thing where as you train the
model the training error gets very small
and then
the attack error gets very small so you
start to be able to like recover
very high faithful you know very
faithful descriptions of individual
training examples
and then only after that does the uh the
actual model performance start to
decrease a lot like you have to kind of
memorize at least in these these these
models they memorize kind of long before
they actually producing good predictions
out of a question what exactly is the
attack here okay what's the attack so
yeah I I skipped over that I was in a
hurry but basically what you're doing is
you look at the model
and you try to find High um
you you try to find examples that
produce very confident predictions
uh so you uh what you do is you sort of
start with uh you know you start with
like a roughly speaking a random example
um and then you sort of just sort of
search locally to to improve the model's
confidence in whatever prediction it's
making
and then you just and it'll tend to
drift close to one of the actual
training examples
at least for certain subpopular for the
subpopulations where there's only one
sub one training example in the data
so you're assuming the attackers
attackers prior knowledge on the
Jonas uh well on cue yeah I mean I guess
the the attack the the this particular
algorithm is somewhat tailored to them
to the setting so there's no it does you
don't assume the attacker knows the
population but that it knows kind of the
class of problems your model is trying
to solve
and like what kind of data your model
was probably trained on
okay
um let's see I'm more or less done that
yeah maybe I'll I guess I'll have to
skip over this I we have another a
follow-up paper that looks at a
similar family of examples
of like a similar family of problems but
looks at not not final model
memorization but intermediate States
during training
and again shows that these intermediate
States even though they're not
predictive models like you don't have to
make predictions per se as you're
training
uh these intermediate states have to be
very big and again there's a sort of an
information theoretic explanation for
the fact that your your intermediate
States for these problems need to store
lots of information about uh exam on
average at least about examples they've
seen during the course of training
and so this gives us a
you know the sort of time space
trade-offs for for so time space
trade-offs were previously known for
other machine learning problems that are
maybe somewhat less natural like things
based on parity for example is more
algebraic problems but this the our
techniques gives give trade-offs for uh
more natural problems like regression
sparse regression type problems that are
like smell a lot more like the kinds of
things one does
um but maybe I'll
um I'll I'll skip over that since I'm
out of time and I'll just go back to
uh this sort of last slide
um this one
and I'll uh and and I'll leave you with
the thought that that I think
information theory has a lot to offer in
terms of shining a light on
um what's going kind of going on inside
these big models
uh and I think these results on
memorization are are kind of that you
know I'm not there there's there's been
lots of efforts to use information
Theory to shine a light on what's going
on inside you know it models uh but
these this is sort of a qualitatively
different take I think from what what
people elsewhere in the literature have
done
and I will stop there and say thank you
very much for listening
thanks Adam I hope you can hear me uh
yeah uh so you mentioned that you kind
of got to this problem thinking about
privacy and it it seems like your
results seems to suggest that privacy is
like fundamentally impossible is that do
you yeah I mean it's you know we are we
have lots of lower bounds for various
kinds of privacy you know on like the
sample complexity for solving problems
under various privacy constraints right
privacy type constraints in fact Giada's
talked just before mine gave you other
such lower bounds you know at some level
um
I I think you know we're I was
interested in sort of
much more extreme examples of of of a
privacy failure than just
um
you you know an inference attack or
something like that so this is like this
is sort of the really extreme version
now the the good news here the positive
news that's you know hidden in these
examples is that in all the problems at
least we can think of
uh where these phenomena happen if you
if you're willing to accept that you'll
get the performance you would have
gotten with less data
like if I'm willing to multiply my data
set size by 10 and like I'm willing to
use 10n examples but get the accuracy I
would have gotten with n
um then we can you you can get away
without all these problems at least for
these for the specific examples we know
so there's sort of a hidden Silver
Lining which is that
um
you know if you're willing to kind of
accept that you can't use all your data
optimally then often you you know these
problems kind of go away
but if if as is the case
in a lot a lot of the time you really
want to like extract every last bit out
of the data you have
then at least there are
you know not crazy settings where that
means you're basically going to have to
like memorize big chunks of your data
thank you
um actually before Adam leaves I wanna I
wanna say something
um when the three of us were I it's a
way of thanking you but I'm gonna say
something but the three of us started
talking about this Outreach oh we've
considered various locations especially
ASU but in 2019 Adam and Katrina and a
bunch of people organize this semester
along
Workshop I don't know semester-long
program
yeah privacy
um Kara at the Simon Says showed and I
had the privilege of being invited
actually organizing mini Workshop Flavio
and Peter and others and and also come
back and give some talks and
Simon's is is just this is such an
amazing place so I'm glad I convinced
them that we should come to status I
don't think we could have done this as
well it's just been so smooth so I don't
have to thank you for
oh well yeah thank you well thank you
for your participation in that program
and for the workshop you organized at
the time and for you the speakers you
brought some of whom are at this this
current Workshop also so thank you to
all of you who spoke
um but yeah Simon's is an amazing place
and I'll take the opportunity to thank
you know both the organizers of this
workshop and the Simon staff
um who do such a fantastic job I guess
the only minor feedback is they have
cameras in the front and they combine
three cameras and do some really awesome
yeah I mean there's all there's a limit
unfortunately I if I if if it had been
feasible logistically for me to get on
an airplane and show up to get the talk
in person I would have prefer to do that
um I would have enjoyed the workshop a
lot more personally but you know such as
well thank you thank you for the talk
and
thank you and I'm happy to answer
questions offline or interact with if
people have other questions anyway
thanks again bye-bye